Salut ! Aujourd'hui est un jour particulier parce que je ne suis pas seul, je suis accompagné non pas d'un magicien réellement, ni d'un mentaliste réellement...
Bien mieux que ça, un tricheur !
Et forcément c'est le sujet de la vidéo mais vous l'aviez vu dans le titre, c'est parti, générique !
[musique]
Et cet homme, ce roi de la triche j'ai envie de dire, c'est Maurice Douda.
Salut mon pote !
-Heu salut ! Tu vas bien ?!
-Ouais, cool. Alors, Maurice il a une particularité: il ne se déplace jamais sans un jeu.
Tu vois. C'est-à-dire que là il est arrivé depuis 10 minutes, je lui dois 200 euros déjà... J'ai même pas compris comment ça se fait. [rires]
-Ouais c'est ça !
-Toi t'as un spectacle à la base Maurice qui s'appelle "Tricheur".
-Oui.
-Que je connais bien.
-Plutôt bien même, même très bien...
-Puisque j'ai collaboré à la mise en scène de ce spectacle.
-J'utilise vraiment des vraies techniques de triche.
-Et ça c'est fou, parce qu'il y a la dextérité qu'il faut avoir et il y a le culot.
Durant son spectacle ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est qu'il y a une caméra qui filme et qui zoom ses mains et c'est retranscrit sur grand écran.
Donc tu ne peux rien rater !
-C'est clair !
-Et pour toi le plus grand tricheur de tous les temps c'est qui ?
-Richard Marcus.
-Richard Marcus ?
-Ouais.
Il a triché pendant 25 ans dans les plus grands casinos du monde et il a ramassé plus de 5 millions de dollars.
-Et c'est un mec qui est toujours vivant ?!
-Ah oui oui, c'est clair, il est toujours vivant puisque je l'ai rencontré via Skype interposé, donc voilà...
-Et son boulot aujourd'hui à Richard Marcus, tu m'arrêtes si je dis une bêtise,
c'est d'être consultant pour les casinos pour leur système de sécurité.
-Exact. Tout à fait.
-C'est-à-dire que le mec les a arnaqué durant des années et aujourd'hui il leur dit: "Eh si vous voulez, je vous empêche qu'un autre mec voulant faire comme moi, ne vienne un jour."
Est-ce que ça te dirais de faire voir un petit peu aux abonnés des techniques de triche ?
Qu'on puisse voir à quoi ça ressemble.
-Ouais.
-Parce qu'en fait c'est toujours un peu nébuleux quand on dit: "Ouais les mecs ils trichent dans les casinos !"... On ne sait pas exactement ce qu'ils y font tu vois ?
Je vais être délicat avec vous mais je vous décroche quand même.
Pas trop le mal de mer ?!
Hop !
Voila...
Ici je vous présente Maurice Douda.
-Salut !
Tiens on va commencer par un truc simple où par exemple le tricheur quand on coupait, quand le jeu était coupé et bien il annulait la coupe.
Mais il annule la coupe par un petit mouvement en allant sur la table par exemple, et hop il faisait une coupe charlier comme ça.
-On a vu ça bouger ouais.
-C'est-à-dire qu'on a vu bouger tu vois, hop je coupe comme ça...
Et tac j'annule la coupe.
Et le fait de le faire dans un mouvement, tout le monde ne suit pas et personne ne voit ce qu'il se passe en fait.
-Tu annules la coupe en bougeant tes jetons et tu es en bonne position pour te donner...
-Oui je suis en bonne position pour me donner l'As.
-Ah ouais c'est dingue !
La question c'est comment je vais me donner l'As ?
Parce que je vais commencer à distribuer ici.
-Ah bah oui c'est ça...
-Donc l'As est au dessus c'est intéressant tu vois.
Donc je vais distribuer comme ça et puis à un moment donné je vais me distribuer l'As.
Et oui, et là vous êtes en train de vous dire mais comment se fait-ce ?
Et bien je vous explique, j'ai triché encore une fois, j'ai fait une donne en second !
-Donc tu donnes la deuxième carte à la place de la première...
-Voilà.
-Vas-y, attends je te filme bien avant de nous faire croire que...
[manipulation des cartes]
-Voilà.
Tu vois si je la mets face en l'air, regarde bien.
Hop !
-A la vache !
[manipulation des cartes]
-Je distribue la deuxième carte !
Génial hein ?!
-Et il ne faut pas casser le rythme !
-Il ne faut pas casser le rythme !
-Mais tu t'es entrainé combien d'heures pour faire ça ? [rires]
-[rires] J'ai une vie passionante je sais...!
C'est ça.
-Est-ce que tu as le droit d'aller dans les casinos ?
-J'ai le droit, oui.
-D'accord.
-Et je suis un petit surveillé quand même.
-Et si tu es vert, orange, ou rouge...
Rouge tu es interdit de casino.
Vert tout allait bien.
Toi tu étais en orange ?!
-Je suis en orange.
-Oui, d'accord.
Ok.
Tu n'as jamais essayé de tricher dans un casino ?
-Non !
-Non ?
-Je n'ai pas envie de finir avec les mains pétées à coups de marteau...
-Oui c'est ça, oui.
Est-ce que d'après toi aujourd'hui de toute manière, est-ce que ça a du sens d'essayer de tricher dans un casino ? Non ?!
-Non. Aucun, aucun, ça ne sert à rien, et du coup après tu seras vraiment interdit de casino si tu essayes de tricher.
Et c'est impossible.
-Quand on parle de la triche on parle de la grande époque de la triche avant toutes les technologies d'aujourd'hui.
Evidemment on ne vous dit pas de tricher. Ne trichez pas, ne cherchez même pas à tricher c'est stupide !
Et en plus c'est inutile, donc c'est deux bonnes raisons de ne pas tricher.
-C'est clair !
-Par contre du coup toutes ces techniques là, aujourd'hui c'est devenu un art et c'est pour ça que tu amènes ça sur scène en fait.
-Ouais, complètement. Tout à fait.
Ça devient un art de voir ça quand tu nous expliques , là on parlait de cartes mais je t'ai déjà vu tricher aussi avec des jetons de poker, ça aussi c'est assez incroyable.
Parce que quand on parle de triche on pense toujours aux cartes, mais on ne pense pas à tout le reste tu vois.
-Ouais, c'est clair. Parce que du coup son coup de bluffe à lui c'était justement avec des jetons de casino.
-Ah oui exactement ! Comment ça s'apellait déjà ?!
-Le coup de bluffe de Savana.
-Ecoute, merci. Alors une dernière technique juste pour nous faire plaisir !
-Un dernière technique... [réfléchi]
Tiens un bonneteau non ?
Tu connais le bonneteau ?
-Ouais.
Bien sur !
Tiens voilà, voilà deux cartes noires, d'accord ? Et une carte rouge.
-Et je vous emmène, vous croyez quoi.
Ok c'est bon.
-Et le truc c'est de suivre la carte rouge.
-Ok.
Facile hein !
Parce que ici c'est noir...
Ici c'est noir,
et là c'est encore noir ! [rires]
C'est bête !
Donc si on vérifie: une, deux, trois cartes noires.
Donc c'est vrai que si tu te dis que là c'est noir,
que là c'est noir, là aussi,
mais tu te dis mais ou est-ce que c'est rouge ? Et bien c'est très tès simple en fait Fab il faut juste frotter un petit peu sur la table.
Et du coup on récupère une carte rouge.
D'accord ?
Et quand on frotte une deuxième fois, on en a une deuxième et une troisième fois, une troisième.
[rires]
Si tu as 1, 2 et 3 cartes rouges, normalement tu ne peux pas perdre !
Ne jouez jamais aux cartes avec moi !
-Le pire c'est qu'en travaillant avec lui, avec mes connaissances en magie, en mentalisme, etc..., je sais ce qu'il fait quand il le fait, mais c'est tellement propre mec !
C'est... c'est encore plus beau en fait !
-Merci Fabien !
-Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur Maurice, je vais mettre un lien vers ton site. Ça te vas ?
-Ouais.
-Dans la descrption.
-Pas de souci.
-Un lien vers le site Internet de Maurice comme ça vous verrez ses réseaux sociaux si vous voulez voir, et tu as pas mal de vidéos en plus sur le site aussi.
-Oui.
-Merci à toi d'etre venu, je te serre la main solennellement.
-Merci mon Fabien !
-Et je recompte mes doigts ! C'est bon tout va bien ! [rires]
Il y a un livre qui existe sur l'univers de la triche qui s'appelle je crois "52 façons de tricher".
Je vais vous mettre le lien dans la descrption directement si vous voulez.
Alors évidemment c'est un livre de culture générale, encore une fois ce n'est pas un livre qui va vous apprendre à tricher, à vous inciter à la faire.
Ce n'est pas du tout l'objet de cette vidéo !
Mais si ça vous interesse d'en savoir plus sur toutes les techniques qui'ils ont développé à cette époque avec un peu le langage qu'ils utilisaient, je vous mets le lien dans la description.
Si ça vous a plu, vous faites quoi ? Un petit pouce en l'air !
Evidemment !
Et le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour, du 1er janvier au 31 décembre ! On approche du bout... mais je ne vais pas arrêter en 2017, je vais vous en reparler très bientot.
Renvez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !
[musique]